hello there
my name is chris ricockis and i'm an
applied mathematics instructor at mit
a senior research analyst at the
university of maryland school of
pharmacy
and the director of scientific research
at pumas ai so what i'm going to talk
about today
is how we are accelerating differential
equations
in r and python using julia's scientific
machine learning ecosystem
so the the key here is really that you
know if you look at what languages
python libraries are written in you see
that you know python is up there
but generally python is written you know
these libraries are written in another
language
so for example if you look at scipy a
lot of the code in there is fortran and
c
and c plus plus right if you look at
tensorflow there's a lot of c
plus plus code in there if you look at
pytorch there's a lot of c
plus plus code in there and so generally
the libraries
that python you know the python
libraries what they're written in
is actually a lower level language and
the reason why this is done
is because you need you know a low-level
compiled language in order to get the
speed that people want out of a library
right what's the reason why you use the
library well because a library
it handles all of the things that you
don't want to be doing right that's
that's the purpose of a library
so you know this is the reason why a lot
of python libraries are not necessarily
written in python
but that gives us a question like why rc
and fortran and such why are those the
languages that are chosen
right so julia is another language that
people kind of talk about like kind of
like python or r
but in a sense julia kind of fits as a c
plus rust kind of replacement right
because you know see julia is as fast as
here fortran windstatic right so
um if you actually if you actually write
code that is good
it will generate the same assembly code
as c plus bus or fortran
and it will be as fast now not everyone
writes
you know perfect julia code but if you
know what you're doing you will get
very fast code and it will match c or c
or fortran and you can check the
generated assembly if you want you know
you could check the
the cindy it is giving you something
that is
that is as fast as you can get so
um that's i mean i mean if your reason
for choosing something like c
plus or uh for or fortran for building a
library is because they're fast
and julia covers that but there's a lot
of other features then that kind of
compound to make it so that way
it might be an interesting choice of a
language for building python libraries
in
right because there's built-in
task-based multi-threading and
distributed
uh computing so for example it's mpi
compatible
and task-based multi-threading is
essentially this idea
that you say that your program is task
one two three four
five six n and then i'll automatically
multi-thread it
it'll choose when to put certain tasks
on it'll jumble them together
so there's a really nice on you know
semi-automated multi-threading
kind of machine that's going under the
hood to make parallelism
easy and the other thing is that there's
escape hatches to dynamic behavior
right so you know if you need a code to
be
slower by getting dynamic behavior but
that part of the code doesn't matter for
performance
you can't do that in julia you you can
just say this is an array that can hold
anything
put a string in there and a integer
and you know it won't be able to
optimize because it doesn't know which
item is in there
but you know it it can make it so that
way it's easier
to build and to build a library the
other thing is that it's able to target
alternative hardware so you know
they've been shown how to how to you
know there are these tools for how to
auto compile your code to tpus and gpus
you can easily support other other chips
like arm
right so this is something that's
generally hard to do in
a language where you have to build
binaries right so you know building
binaries in a way that you make file is
incompatible with arm and power
pc and everything right if if you try to
take tensorflow and just
put it on a weird architecture it's
probably not going to work without
you know someone who who's working on
the code working with you on it
but with julia right it's it's you you
never end up with binaries that are
compiled with msvc but
you know et cetera et cetera but you
don't have these binary issues
because it jit compiles so as if as long
as the julia
programming language works on that
machine the package
that is written in julia will work in
that machine so with by changing the
julia what we have found
was that you know it's much easier to
support many different architectures
because jet compilation
has that added bonus that you never have
you know you never really have to worry
about
the binary shipping and all the issues
associated with it
and one of these one of the issues
that's fixed along with that that kind
of
follows the same vein is julia's
reproducible package manager right so
a lot of package management issues come
down to the way that they have to handle
shipping binaries or building binaries
on a user computer
and all of the issues that can go wrong
with that um but julia because
because you're just shipping julia code
and the compiler is with the user
because the julia programming language
as the compiler you know the manifest
captures all of the versions that the
that the user is supposed to have so it
just sends them the correct versions of
the julia source
and boom when you run the code you'll be
able to get that same result
you know independent of your machine and
independent
of you know which day you ran it or you
know what what other things you had
installed in your computer
right so there's these reproducible
environments that capture everything
right so normally in other programming
languages like our python or
you know rust and all these languages
with binaries
you usually have to make sure they have
docker installed because you know these
binaries are going to be calling these
system libraries
and you know the math the system math
library on linux is going to be
different than windows and all those
but with julia it's it's julia code
under the hood and so it's shipping you
the same one
and so these issues that you're usually
using docker for
aren't really required and so you know
you can really simplify down
your your your your path to production
or your path shipping your library
and the other thing is that it's
interactive and dynamic right this is
why people think about it as
you know python or our kind of uh you
know competitor
but in a sense what that means is it's
you can also think about it as just like
a
easier version of c or fortran right you
know it's it's almost like you're
writing c or fortran but with all the
python niceties right you're using an
ide
that has an interactive terminal there
um you're getting your feedback
immediately
you can change your package in the
middle of your writing it so that way
you can
you know very easily debug what's going
on in there
all of those things that you want to do
in an interactive dynamic language
you can do it with julia even though
it's giving you something out that is
you know library level
kind of code in the end and there's also
a large package ecosystem of numerical
and scientific packages
and a lot of these packages are not
necessarily in python or for
or python or are yet right so for
example there's a lot of things in
blockbanded matrices
you know a lot of really odd you know
portions of linear algebra for
specializing in accelerating code
a lot of those things i can only find in
julia
and so this is kind of like a nice thing
that we might want to have in in the
python world right so
instead of building you know instead of
building language wars let's let's build
bridges right um let's try to make it so
that way we can use libraries from julia
in python as just you know julie can
then be another one of these languages
that the python libraries are built on
top of
so what would add to the python
experience um
you know the one that i work with is the
scientific machine learning open source
software ecosystem
called cyaml so i'm not going to define
too much what scientific machine
learning is it's the
incorporation of machine learning like
neural networks into
scientific simulations and models so
doing things like automated discovery of
physics
and um and accelerating physical
simulators by
you know training neural networks to
replace parts of them so this scientific
machine learning
open source software organization really
only has the tools
written in julia right but yeah
a lot of these things don't exist in
other languages and so what we've been
looking to do
is actively make sure that we can
support these
audiences in other languages in order to
make sure that our tools get out there
and people's
you know scientific problems are solved
and so there's a lot of tools like you
know the differential equation solvers
the difficulty flux package for
universal differential equations
and you know neural differential
equations modeling toolkit which is one
that you probably haven't heard of but
it will show up in this
talk as like this little secret weapon
that we have um
neural pde which is all about neural
network solvers for physics and foreign
neural networks
and and deep bsd methods for 100
dimensional partial differential
equations
we have differentiable chemical reaction
network methods
you know high performance differentiable
molecular dynamics simulators
all these kinds of things that add
differentiable programming to
physical simulation game simulation and
all that you can find in
this iml open source software right so
this is this is something that you know
is at the front edge of a lot of
research and so
what we want to do is we would we just
want to share this with the largest
audience that we can
and you know so why why would you care
about these
this specific software um well one of
the reason
um that people like to look at it is
because you know
the differential equations library does
outperform a lot of the other libraries
that you see
in high level languages right and you
know for example
if you if you're to compare it to you
know um
to something like matlab or something
like scipy
you'll see about you know order or order
to magnitude of difference in
in the timing so i'm going to show a few
of these plots let me describe it a
little bit
on here you see the error versus the
time so you know you can
the basically the the solvers are ran
multiple times
um with with the with a given tolerance
they're checked against a reference
solution with
which is computed with 512 bit you know
high precision numbers um and then
against that that
reference solution then you can
calculate what the true error is
right and so you can then look at you
know if i'm to change the solver
tolerances
how long does it take to solve the
solution and what is the true error that
i get
and so you can this is what we call work
precision because it's
how much work do you take to get this
amount of precision and to get the same
amount of
air you can use these julia sulfurs to
you know get you know you can get the
same amount of air for
for in a solution from a julia solver
with about 50 times to 100 times
acceleration in comparison to some other
high-level languages
so normally this is what we look at as a
reason to say well maybe
you could use julia but i think the the
more interesting thing here is
if you're a python user you might want
to ask why
why or why is this speed up right so
some of it is due to language right so
some of it is due to the fact that
the differential equation that you're
giving to the solver
it has to be a function in the solver's
language and so if you're writing that
in a high level language that could slow
you down
but a lot of it is algorithmic right so
if
you look at for example you know the
julius appears
julia solvers you know giving fast
function pointers to
the fortran and c plus boss library so
that way you know everyone's on fair
ground
um if you look at that case you still
see that you know
for example vern 7 and dp5 and in this
bot over here
you're getting you know almost an order
of magnitude better than
some of these c plus or fortran
libraries you know uh
doing better than things like ls oda
which is the
which is the fortran code underlying the
uh scipy od and method right um you also
see the same thing over here when you
look at
um the pleiades you know so this is a
hundred by a hundred a linear odes this
is 28
um odes both non-stiff and you still see
that you know
things like um ls oda and and and
sundials you know they're being
outperformed by these julia methods
because there's been a whole lot of work
over these recent years to be able to
optimize these methods
so you know there's things about these
algorithms that you might want to use
from from python just to accelerate you
know over what you might have
in in sci pi you know these these older
methods and it's not just in non-stiff
equations right so non-stiff equations
are like the
the non-technical ones um you know the
highly technical ones that that take
years to develop the solver for
now we've been able to crack the code in
julia after
about five years of working on this
we're you know we've had a total like 40
contributors so it's been a pretty large
project to get there
but for example if you look at seven
stiff odes then you have you know for
example
you know that this rodos 5 method is
able to get
about half an order of magnitude so 5x
acceleration
over things like uh cvod bdf and
you know so sundials um the 4chan radar
code
you know if you go to low enough
tolerance we we don't win all these
benchmarks we have
enough benchmarks to know where we're
doing well and where we do not
but in general our benchmarks are doing
fairly good
um and this even scales to very large
stiff equations so for for example
here's the bcr
equations which is um of 1122
very stiff odes and in this case what we
see is
you know about it's about half an order
of magnitude between
sundials and one of the um one of the
differential equations such al methods
so you know even on stiff non-stiff
equations
there are there are reasons to be
calling these julia solvers
even from python right um and
it comes with a ton of wrappers because
you know how do we do all these
benchmarks
well we made really good wrappers for
all these different you know codes from
fortran c
plus et cetera in order to make sure
that we can do these benchmarks
and do this research and so i mean that
itself you know connecting
python to all those different um to to a
system that has all these things already
wrapped and already
shipped and ready to go you know that
that's a useful software there in itself
right so here for example um is an
example with 600 semi-stiff odes
here we do okay if uh with one of the
pure julia methods for a bit
and here we have sundials doing uh
beating the pure julia methods for part
of it right
and so you know you want to switch
between all of them you want to have all
that freedom
you know and about 90 of the time the
pure julia methods do best
but for all the other times we built
this whole system where you can easily
with one piece of code just switch
between a bunch of different
wrappers from different packages right
so you know scipy difficult matlab
difficult
lsoda.jl these are all different julia
packages
and julia's multiple dispatch system
puts it all into one interface
so that way over 300 solver methods can
be called from the same interface
so that would be a good thing to you
know ship to other languages because
it's just a
very big differential equation solver
ecosystem
and if this is what you're doing daily
this could be something that's useful
right so this is really what we want to
be shipping and
what else what else could be useful in
in these other languages
well the the key thing is that it's not
really all about speed all the time
right
a lot of it is sometimes about features
so here here's a really bizarre model
that you might want to write right so
you have this model where if a cell gets
enough protein x
it splits into two cells so you have a
lot of these biological simulations
where things are growing
and dying and changing size and the
julia differential equation solver
ecosystem
has all these capabilities so that way
you can say you know when
the protein when the number inside of a
cell equals one
then change you know change that that
array value that was 1
2 theta create a new part of the array
which is 1 minus theta
and keep on solving the differential
equations right so you can
be solving a stiff equation that is
changing the number of you know the
changing the number of equations
as you're solving it you know so all
these weird dynamic behaviors that would
be difficult in of in a
language like c plus plus or 4chan right
where you
don't have as much dynamism all those
features that would be difficult are
really straightforward to do
with the julia library sim so this would
be something that you know you might
want to make use of because this kind of
hybrid behavior and this change in
behavior
on on on implicit quantities inside of a
differential equation
are you know of a very odd thing and
most libraries don't support it
right and the key is that we really
combine features with speed so
here for example is a neural
differential equation which you can
you can train one of these neural odes
in about 30 lines of code
and if you're to look at this in
comparison to something like torched if
eq
you know they're they're the example
from the neural ods paper so you have
taken
taken their code that they've optimized
you can see that that you know you get
about 100x difference
training the neural ode from difficult
loss and you see very similar
differences when you go to
you know these very more much more
obscure types of equations like
stochastic differential equations
so it's really about you know the the
features and the obscure
features and then more and more you know
down on the down in the weeds
it's about having all those features
with the speed associated with it
um it's also about inference right so
one of the things
one of the other things we want to make
sure that we can get to the python
libraries
is this ability due to parameter
estimation so for example you can do
things like you can define
a stochastic differential equation and
you can recover the drift and diffusion
parameters
even when they're non-zeros right you
can
you can do things like pd constrained
optimization and you can
learn the parameters of differential
algebraic equations
delay differential equations and now
it's really getting into the weeds and
probably
some people probably haven't heard of
these equations but you know weird
weird differential equation we put data
in good
numbers out right um this this is this
is the thing that we do
and this is the thing that we want to
share right um
and so the the key that is going to be
difficult for how we can
you know utilize things in another
language is the composability aspect
so i mentioned that you know for example
you can define equations where
you know whenever whenever you hit some
implicit constraint you can have a jump
in the equation
you're mixing these jumps and odes
stiffness all these things together
and you just piece the code together
well here's an example doing that where
you know
the differential equation itself is
defined by a neural network
right you can train the neural network
embedded in this differential equation
that is defined by
you know things moving around things
jumping things implicitly
changing or you can just take all these
features
and just kind of compose them together
this is the part that we're going to say
you know
we're not going to get here yet in the
wrapper but you know a lot of the things
before the composability are things that
we'll be able to wrap
because this composability kind of comes
from a few of uh julia's weirder
features and stronger language features
so what we're going to at least try to
get get to
is the performance and the features
right these are the things that we're
going to try to get to
you know are in python um
so another one of these aspects that
we're able to
demonstrate that we would also like to
get to python libraries is the
ability to automatically detect sparsity
in code right because
you know there's a natural sparsity
pattern that you have
in the code that you're writing down
given which features are interacting
with
with which others and these sparse
jacobians and sparse hessians
are useful in a lot of cases um when
doing
you know scientific machine learning or
other types of scientific computing so
these this is another one these features
that we then want to
make sure work in in the python
ecosystem
when we're doing the package wrapping
another aspect that we want to be able
to share is the ability to work on
gpus so for example um here what i'm
showing is that you know
we have examples where the the climate
climate climate modeling um
the klima climate model is making use of
these differential equation solvers
with mpi and gpu it's involved with imax
methods
rock methods you know things it is also
it is not just a personal differential
equation solver
but it's also a climate scale
differential equation solver
so could we make sure that these
features work as well
when we get things over to these other
languages
and another nice nice feature is the
idea that you know we can make gpus work
on small equations
so generally small equations are not
things that you can gpu accelerate
but if you need to solve the same small
equation with 10 000
different initial conditions this is
something that we've been able to use
compiler tricks
to be able to automatically you know
speed up and you can look at the case
study that we linked there
which is all about how for one of
pfizer's internal models
we're able to use this tool to be able
to give 175x acceleration
to their internal code
and the last last but not least you know
the reason to link
cyaml over to these other languages is
because it's about the
future right so here is neuralpd.jl
which is a way to
you know automate pdes in different ways
with neural networks
so here is one way to be able to
automate the solution where
you give us so you give a partial
differential equation in a
you know very symbolic form and then say
we'll just take that differential
equation and give you back a solution
where the solution is generated via
neural networks right
so this is neural pde um and so
sometimes
some of the things that we have in in
the science ecosystem
are these you know unique kind of
nuggets and i think these are also the
kind of things that we want to make sure
we can
somehow allow python users to make use
of
so how do we build a bridge into these
other languages
such that people can actually use these
tools from you know
you don't have to necessarily adopt
julia to be able to use these
libraries and these features that i
showed
so we've been able to do this through
these different language wrappers so the
one that's been very successful
is difficult qr this is the um the
differential equation solvers with a
wrapper for the
r programming language so this is the
one i'm going to describe first because
of how much success this one has had so
difficult is all about fast differential
equations solving an
r by a julia right so here's what the
code looks like on the left
um if you did if you know r you'll see
that this is
you know very standard r code right
you're you're just saying you know load
the uh divi qr library
you know set up this differential
equation solver that that step is in
admittedly word step but what it does in
the background is is basically getting
the
underlying julian engine spun up to be
ready for doing the differential
equation solving
and then you define a differential
equation you call solve
and boom it gives you a solution all
right
now the reason why this library is
interesting and useful is that we've
been able to make it so that way
you can write pr code and get a 350x
acceleration
over desolve which is the one of the
widely used
or probably the most widely used um uh
library in r and it's not because r d
solve
is bad at all amd solve is actually a
very good
wrapper for fortran codes in r but what
we've been able to do is we've been able
to make this library ship
with a specialized jet compiler to be
able to turn the user's r code
into julia code and be able to eliminate
a lot of the overhead
but that would occur naturally when you
write this function in r right so
remember that the part that is don't
generally slow
in some of these scientific computing
codes is the fact that
if you have a higher order function you
know this this
function f is written in the higher
level language and so this is the thing
that we need to accelerate
and what we've been able to do with the
stiffy qr library
is we've been able to make it so that
way we can accelerate this behind the
scenes
without requiring the user to do very
much
how did we get there well it's a
combination of julia call
differential equations.jail and this
secret tool i mentioned earlier called
modeling toolkit
so this is what the differentia this is
what the diffie-qr library looks like
it's about three or four functions like
this so it's a
source code is about 100 lines of code
and
um one of those lines of code defines
this way of
doing package import and auto wrapping
and then we
do auto wrapping of the of the library
right
there there's this weird thing right
here which basically says
i'm going to search for all of the
functions in the julia library
and then it automatically builds a
wrapper over all of these functions and
imports the library and so you know if
we go back here
what what this is doing in the
background is it takes the underlying
julia and it sets up the back end so
that way
it loads differential equations and it
gives you all of the functions from the
differential equation library
so you know this this od problem
function is from julia this d
solve function is from julia and what we
did was we exposed
all of these functions as they would
normally be in the julia documentation
as just um fields of this d e
object so that way you know if you read
the documentation for the julia
differential equation solvers
you'll know how to use any of these
features in r
and we made sure you know we went
through and we did have to specifically
wrap some of these solution parts
so that we'd have some of the automated
solution features like automated
interpolations and such
but um this is this is really it you
know this
and the the function for how to do the
auto importing
this is it and this made it so that way
we could
do build this library and document to
users how to
use the differential equation solvers
from r
and i'm going to have to explain this
little modeling toolkit portion that's
associated with the jet
but before that the last detail is does
it do
everything for you it's not all the way
there yet
so i think that we still need to get the
automated installation process
at this point you still need to make
sure that you have already installed
julia
but we're trying to get an automated
installation of julia going
so how did we get the the jet portion
working and
so the key is we we built this thing
called modeling toolkit ization
so that way if users gave us bad code in
julia
then we can turn that bad code into good
code
right so your user writes a code that is
not fast
if you don't know why this is not fast
well this is a tool for you right so
you know we usually wrote down a code
that's not fast we do modeling
tokenization
we rebuild a new problem and this is a
faster version of the problem
it actually accelerates the stiff od
solving by about 10x
so if you want to hear all about this
tool you can watch this video that i
gave
for julie con 2020 but but the key idea
behind it
is that you know it it is a symbolic
language that matches julia's
language itself and so we can
automatically turn code into symbolic
versions of the code and then we can
perform transformation so we can do
things like
calculate the jacobian of someone's code
or calculate the sparsity pattern and
the jacobian of the code
and from that we can build you know
whatever version of their code that we
wanted
because we're just understanding it as
we just need to make sure the numbers
flow in the same way
we don't really care if you what kind of
array or something you used
so we're going to change your array
we're going to make it a better one etc
and and with that freedom we can then
optimize a lot of codes
so this was kind of built at first for
julia usage
but if you can do that code you know
that same way of kind of analyzing the
code
from a different language then you get
the same features
so this is actually what we're able to
do with r so
with r what we were able to do is we're
able to run this program analysis
through a limited form of our code so it
does need to be something that's
essentially
a mathematical model but on on that
on the limited language that we do
support it is fast because
what it does is it takes the the um the
art code
and it's able to use modeling
tokenization to be able to put into a
symbolic language
once it's in that symbolic language then
it's able to build a julia function that
is optimized the way we want it
and then the whole solution takes place
in julia and so there's no r to julia
you know
going back and forth anymore it's a pure
julia portion here in the solve
and then we just give everything back to
r in it after the solve is done
and because of this everything that we
want to do from the julia side so
differentiable programming
you know putting having the ability to
do
adjoints with neural networks and now
all these features that we want to do
with um
uh happening compiling to gpus you know
all of these things work so
you know the easiest way to gpu
accelerate od
solves in r is to define it in this
library
you know just call the jet optimized ode
function which will then build the julia
code
and then just use the julia functions
for doing gpu accelerated od solving
um and then i'll spit out the solution
it will transform it back to
r for you and there you go so the
corollary is that you can actually use
this to build
automatic differentiation into r using
julia so
if you're interested in that kind of
thing that could be a fun little project
but this is something that's already
fairly useful to our users so
we've been very happy with the feedback
we've been getting because we've been
getting quite a nice user base for
you know this this tool um but what
about python you know that that thing
right there that you know
it's pi data right so what about python
well
we did build a difficupi which is a fast
differential equation solving library
in python with julia and so here is an
example where you can you know define
a stochastic differential equation with
diagonal noise
you just compiled your your f and g
functions with number
you give them to the julia differential
equation solvers and boom what comes out
is a solution to the stochastic
differential equation
um a lot of the library is wrapped you
can use a lot of it
but it's not quite perfect yet uh why do
i say it's not quite perfect
well currently because the auto tool
auto modeling toolkitzation
uh fails and number doesn't really quite
cut it because
you know so i kind of go into details in
a blog post here
where essentially it's essentially why
number and cython aren't able to do as
well here
is because whenever you kind of have
this you know the context change
you can get a lot of you know you can
get a lot of performance decreases due
to that
and so just because you check compile
doesn't mean that you know
you're getting the full speed so the
summary is really that
you know what you need to do is you need
to eliminate the function call overhead
you need to do interprocedural
optimizations
and those are things that are hard to do
if you just compile that function
separately
you do get some tweeters but you know
you you don't get all of them
and so the current fastest way to use
the difficulty pi library
is you you write a string for the julia
function um
and then that then you eval it in julia
and then that you'll get full
performance from but you know it's
this does work where you just write a
pure python function you tell it to
compile and you solve it but it doesn't
give you the full speed of this yet
it's about you know 2.5 x lower than
what we know is like the speed of light
so you know the current best solution is
the eval function
that deserves a frowny face and this is
something that we are
actively working on so um you know just
just to kind of show that
this is actually getting some traction
in python you know the the
num focus uh library um pi bam
is making use of this so for example
pybam used to make use of
uh it used to generate his code uh
symbolic code for cassati
which would then go to sundials um that
took about 7.5
milliseconds to solve um i actually just
snapshotted this right off my computer
where what we've done is we've optimized
the um the
the jewelry cut that's being generated
from this process and showed that we can
get about
you know 10x acceleration over this uh
cassadi
um sun tiles kind of setup that they had
before and so
um for the so this library this python
library for doing battery modeling
we've been working with the developers
so that way they can actively make use
of the julia differential equation
solvers
as a back end for their battery model
simulations and so you
pretty some pretty large organizations
are starting to put this to use
so what are the things that we still
need to do to really get to the point
that we want to be at
well i want to really get this modeling
tool calization working from python so
that way
at least on you know a limited subset of
mathematical kind of looking codes
we can get the full julia performance
from you for users in python
and what we would also want to make sure
that we do for this library and the r
version of it is automate the
installation of julia i think if you if
you're a python user or
or an r user you shouldn't have to know
how to install julia
you know pip should do this before for
you in the background and so
you know this is something that we're
actively working on we actually have
prototypes
i was hoping the prototypes would be
done before the video but i think that
you know we're about two or three months
away so
probably the next time you hear from me
um it'll probably be done
and so you know it should it will
essentially be you you say pip installed
difficult and then boom in the
background everything should be ready
for you to just
instantly start running one of the other
things that we're looking into
is compiling the differential equation
solvers into the system image of that
julia that we ship
so that way everything is already
pre-compiled for you so that way there's
no jit lag
at all it'll essentially be like the c
or fortran binary
um one one of the one of the last things
too is we want to try to make it so that
way we can allow python neural networks
so for example pi torch and jacks we
want to allow you to be able to find
those in the differential equations
of the the peaky pi differential
equation solvers so that way you can use
it with our neural
uh neural differential equation tools so
this is something that
um we're aiming for hopefully within
within the next year
um we did and we did recently get a num
focus sponsorship
and you know our and we're using that to
build on our already
you know we have a pretty large
developer pool but we're really trying
to
grow that as well to kind of make sure
we can handle these responses and these
requests coming from
you know the rn python communities
so um if you want you can help us build
bridges right so
the thing that that is the easiest thing
that you can do to help us out
is to start a repository so differential
equations.jail is our main one
um ordinary different q difficulty r
difficult
if you can star these these are one ways
to be able to show that people are
interested in these libraries
and are interested in these kind of you
know cross cross-language collaborations
and so it would be very helpful for us
to you know be able to get
further funding to make sure that we can
build more bridges um
and that last but not least i want to
thank all of the developers and sorters
the supporters of sayamal there's
there's way too many to list here so i'm
just going to list
you know some of the students who have
really been driving this right so
ingoma khan of gupta shashi goda uh
harrison grodin
and valentine shravi um all of their
work you know have been used in a lot of
these libraries and so
a lot of open source is built by
students who should be getting the
recognition
for the work that they're doing so thank
you very much and i hope that you
if you're into differential equation
solving i hope you find these tools
useful
if not if you're just interested in
possibly building a library in python
using julie underneath the hood
i hope this was informative and if you
need more information
feel free to contact me because i can
help you get started and help these
things get running
so thank you very much